communicate does it turn you on if a
girl speaks your enemies no really
because it makes me feel like I'm
talking to my sister oh does that turn
you on okay
what if she's not Vietnamese she's
Ethiopian and she studied Vietnamese to
be closer to you because she busts out
the Vietnamese would you go oh that's an
egg roll time
I think that would be a really hot chick
it's talking to you but she's talking to
Vietnamese that's your sister you're
throwing up
that's a sister I'm thinking about
actually have you ever dated a
Vietnamese girl that speaks Vietnam uh
no not really it's hard it's hard
there's nothing wrong with it if you're
racist it's fine if you're racist dude
no there is not everyone's significant
others from a different culture yeah see
how do you feel about that why are you
looking down on us no I'm not he's lucky
he's judging us are you up here looking
down here